It's elegant when painted
A long and beautiful Tsuko with unrivaled functional beauty A
client is possible An animal with a cool side
It's
a calcium deficiency.
I'm going to get porosis, and moreover, I
'm going to have osteoporosis.
If you
don't need it, you can't make such a luxurious thing, can you?
The main body is in tatters, but the
land price can eat a lot of rice and repair the house, but
horses have a weak stomach, so they don't have the strength to repair the house
.
Deer are digested and absorbed properly, so they don't have the original form of food,
but
horses are pretty much the same
.  It's beautiful because you put horns on a horse that isn't beautiful.